today we are going to examine what is
probably the oldest cookbook in medieval
europe or very nearly so it exists in
four different manuscripts two are in
low german one in danish and one in
icelandic
they can be dated somewhere around 1300
or maybe even a little earlier it's
called the le bellas de arte coconaria
and as you can probably tell the title
and the recipe titles themselves are in
latin now what this suggests is that
it's a translation of an older work that
no longer exists and was written out for
a variety of patrons who wanted to serve
elegant meals with imported ingredients
and by imported i mean in particular
spices that came from india and what's
now indonesia things like cloves and
cinnamon and nutmeg and pepper and these
traveled across the entire new world to
get to iceland which had just been
settled by vikings a few centuries
before now clearly they kept up trade
contacts with mainland europe now in
many respects these recipes resemble
those of later better known medieval
cookbooks like the form of curry in
england and even the libre de senso v in
catalonia that's because medieval
aristocratic cuisine was very
international there was a small landed
military elite who mostly wanted to
imitate each other they were rarely
educated so i can imagine these were the
kind of texts that might have been
copied out by a clergyman or a learned
secretary and brought to these far-flung
courts with explanations on how to use
these exotic ingredients and at the end
of one of the manuscripts the translator
or maybe even the copyists wrote in
latin this little book on culinary art
is finished thanks be to god let the
copyist go play amen and you can you can
almost picture this person sort of
dictating in his monks cowl you know and
the recipes themselves
are terse um they have no literary
pretensions and so we will have almost
completely free hand with the
measurements and the cooking times
exactly as a medieval cook would who
probably you know heard these read out
loud and had to then figure out how to
prepare them and his master may very
well have been among those who maybe
went to the holy land fought in the
crusades and made it home now and wanted
some reminder of his adventure and what
better way than a thick spicy sauce to
go in his haunch of flesh and there are
also internal clues that suggest that
this is meant for a noble audience
interestingly the recipes are all for
meat fowl and fish and then sauces to go
with them there's no fruit or vegetables
and people sometimes assume oh that must
mean because medieval people didn't eat
them
and it's true actually physicians warned
people about the cold phlegmatic humors
that could arise from fruits especially
but i think their relative scarcity in
cookbooks is more that these were not
really items of prestige or luxury
especially if you could grow them at
home
but almonds on the other hand those are
imported from the south and they feature
here especially almond milk which was
used
during lent and fasting days as a milk
substitute that's not a modern invention
surprisingly enough so i'd like to point
out that the language of some of these
manuscripts is very close to old english
and a speaker of modern english can
almost make out what they mean for
example
and stacker them well one should take
bream and pike or other fish and roast
them well now what exactly the author
means by roast should not be confused
with baking though there are recipes for
pies they also have oven technology and
baked bread but i think by the roast
what he what we would think of as
grilling on the other hand as you'll see
the sauce is made from the drippings so
i think this this should be in a pan
over a fire what's called hunter style
fish and obviously you don't hunt for
fish so i think this means the sort of
dish that could be prepared easily and
quickly outdoors while on the hunt of
course which is exactly what a nobleman
did when not fighting wars
so the recipe also says to baste with
the oil mentioned earlier and what um
that's the base for the sauce
the only oils that are mentioned before
are walnut oil or almond oil
both are actually made from scratch by
pounding the nuts and wringing out the
the oil through a cloth and again the
logic is that these would be appropriate
for lent so we're going to base the fish
while it's roasting with the oil and
when that's done we'll we're told to
take of the oil and blend it with
vinegar and wring it through a cloth in
other words we're straining out any
solid bits and as for the type of
vinegar it seems unlikely that this
would be a
vine based you know wine vinegar since
that would have to be imported
this far north so it doesn't seem likely
that they would import olive oil since
they're making nut oil so my guess is
that it's made from something either
beer or apple cider or maybe even mead
combined with the nut oil these make a
really interesting dressing but not an
expensive one and this is a recipe you
can easily do away from home now the
question is why would they be using
imported spices but not oil and vinegar
and i think it must be that though the
weight and the long distance wouldn't
really make these profitable um though
we know they certainly imported wine and
in fact even in beowulf they drank ale
mead and on a few occasions wine and
interestingly everything goes wrong when
they drink wine which is a you know a
foreign kind of drink but let's compare
that one to a recipe for mustard and
we're told to grind the mustard seeds
and add a third part of honey and a
tenth part of anise and twice as much of
cinnamon and regarding the provenance
here the mustard and the anise they
actually can be grown in europe and
obviously the honey too
but it's the cinnamon that comes from
what is now sri lanka that makes this a
noble dish the herbs are ground mixed
with the vinegar put in a cask and it
will last three months and many of the
recipes seem concerned about how long
you can keep a dish or a sauce around
and i'm not really sure why you would
need to make this in advance though it's
a really interesting mustard and maybe
you know might even improve with age but
but the sauce for lord includes these
things cloves nutmeg cardamom pepper
cinnamon ginger toasted bread vinegar uh
and this one lasts for half a year
[Music]
so now we're going to cook from the
labelis and it will seem strange
primarily because it's a pie but it has
bones in it now keep in mind
uh we're meant to be uh they were meant
to be a form of preservative the pie
itself i mean the sealed dough keeps out
the oxygen and these are medieval
recipes
um sometimes they have a deer inside
i've seen some with oyster shells and
everything so these can be used to make
pasties of fish or foul or actually
anything but this one specifies a young
chicken
and we could cut it in two we could keep
it whole whichever way i'll i'll leave
that to you but i think you could easily
use a little game hen that's what we
found for this and uh it'd be very
pleasant serving for one person just a
tiny little pie with a game hand inside
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take this little chicken and we're
going to cover it with the um
the
leaves
and i just have some fresh sage here
um and of course you would want to salt
it right now
it doesn't specify that but salt in and
out and maybe even put some sage leaves
inside the cavity like that
and then i'm gonna wrap
take this take off the stems put some
sage in like that
just leave these whole
and then
i'm going to wrap this in bacon okay and
they don't i don't know what exactly
kind of bacon they had but this will do
fine
i'm gonna bring that over here
i think
three maybe let's give it one more why
not be generous
okay
put that aside
okay so for this recipe i'm going to use
rye i think it's appropriate for
the region northern europe and
scandinavia and iceland of course but
also because rye was used in these early
pies
because it doesn't break when you bake
it and the pie this is going to be
really strange doesn't include fat and
that's led most scholars to conclude
that the crust wasn't actually eaten
that it's just kind of a a coffin a
coffer to hold all the contents and act
as a preservative so it's really kind of
odd through the course we're going to
actually follow different types of pies
and see how they're made um eventually
they will have a fat in them eventually
butter will go in so we'll see that that
evolution happened very slowly and
interestingly but to start with it's not
a um
it's not an edible crust probably
although you know once you put it in
here and it's got the bacon and
everything i think it probably will
taste very good and my sort of you know
experience with all this seems to say
well if someone's gonna go to the
expense of growing
um
a grain are you really gonna throw it
away and throw away the crust you're
gonna make it you know as edible as you
possibly can so so let's just make this
crust for this and i'm going to wrap it
in this and there's really not much more
to it but let me
show you how to make a fairly simple
medieval pie
early medieval pie i should say by the
time we get to the
it's really not until the 15th century
that you find butter in the crust and
something that looks like a crust that
we would eat um
and then sometimes lard and sometimes
suet or other type of fat but this
doesn't have it in there at all
so
okay i'm not sure this is going to be
big enough i mean you do want this
fairly thick so it's
not going to fall apart but let's see
all this cover our little bird
okay
i think this will work okay
[Music]
and we're just going to need a little
top for this
right on top
and actually i have one little part here
that came out let me just fix that we
want this nicely sealed up
so this would normally be baked right on
the floor of a brick oven um but you
could use a baking stone that's what
i've got in there to get the same effect
um or put a piece of parchment down i
put this into a
baking pan just because i think it's
going to probably leak some grease from
all that bacon and i don't want it to go
into the up floor of the oven but the um
but the the dough of course is gonna
take the shape of the chicken
and the beauty of this dish is that
normally if you were to bake a chicken
all the juices would just run out you'd
have you'd have to make a sauce from
those like right a modern baked chicken
if you throw it in the oven but here
we'll let this cool down to room
temperature after baking and the juices
should remain um within and be absorbed
by the dough and i think it might
actually be edible we'll see what
happens but for the moment i'm going to
put in the oven and i'm going to give
this at least an hour to bake and i
think because we want the bacon to cook
through and the whole chicken and
everything together so into the oven it
goes
[Music]
to go with these recipes i'd like to
walk you through a fascinating archaic
technique i know a lot of people do
really serious home brewing nowadays and
most people either buy the
malted barley or they might buy a
pre-made liquid wart and very reliable
yeasts and hops and use all sorts of
fancy equipment and airlocks and things
like that to make make the beer
taste good right
and that's exactly what we'll not do in
this episode i've done this a few times
and actually the first time i did it
with a kit from the chemist boots in
england when i was only 13 years old
that was my first batch of beer and the
kids are fine but rarely as good as what
the pros can do so i think you know the
same thing is true with wine and it's
you know wine is actually much easier to
make i do that with grapes every fall
it's just a few bottles are pressed by
hand but i think um you know beer is a
lot more complicated um and what i want
to capture here is is something
that readers of the labelis would have
had in the 13th century in northern
germany or denmark or even in iceland
and to start the one big difference is
that they would have used wild yeast and
we're going to do that too
they didn't use hops at this point
either more common was a mixture of
herbs called kraut and it's actually the
same word as kraut which means just
vegetables it would usually contain
mugwort that's artemisia vulgaris which
is a bitter and acts as a preservative
maybe also they'd had yarrow or henbane
which is hallucinogenic and a whole
series of other herbs which were
actually kept a secret because someone
was granted the exclusive right to sell
this kraut
for to the beer makers but we'll just
stare with stick with mug wharton as you
can tell from the name in english it's
for the mug it's for ale right
a few other things to keep in mind
through most of the middle ages beer was
made in the home on a very small scale
and almost always by women
in england this would be called the
alewife who might run a small operation
out of her kitchen um or maybe even a
small tavern-like operation uh gradually
commercial operations increased in scale
and once they started using hops they
could actually ship beer much further it
was done
say in the hanseatic league cities in
germany up through the baltic sea and
then finally the dutch also get very
good at large-scale professional brewing
another thing to keep in mind is this
was not the light lager that we're
familiar with which is you know bottom
fermented and a cold cellar this is
actually top fermented meaning the yeast
will be floating on top
so we would call this ale
to start with we also need to malt the
barley and for this you need whole
grains not pearled barley but what looks
like this is
just barley okay and to make the malt
what we're gonna do is just soak these
in water overnight i'm just gonna fill
this whole thing this is about two and a
half pounds of barley um so obviously
i'm making it on a very very small scale
this is gonna make
i don't know how much it may be a couple
of gallons um
we're just gonna soak this
and then in the next morning
you will drain this off
and then keep changing the water ever
for about two or three days um i also
gave you some
wheat here just so you can see the
difference wheat is looks very very
different from barley it's a much
smaller and you can use wheat to make
beer but the barley
actually changes the enzyme when it's
sprouted will actually
help to convert the starches in the
grain into sugar
so you want to keep them not too wet and
then the sprout end you can see if you
look at these very closely they have
little rootlets that are sticking out of
them and they also have a sprout
okay that's in there so this has just
been three days
sitting um you can see they're still
just a little moist um i just kept them
in the house you don't have to put this
outside or anything and there's one has
just escaped but you can see so when the
when the root end
is about the same size as the grain
itself you can see that right there then
that's ready to make into malt and you
can also actually add oats sometimes rye
is added to it or wheat and that's going
to give it a different flavor darker
color so in northern europe this would
have been done over a very low flame
with smoke and that would of course
flavor the beer exactly as it does in
whiskey um and of course you know
whiskey is just basically distilled beer
so what i suggest you should do is put
it in the oven at about 200 degrees and
leave it overnight and it will
completely dry out but you don't want to
actually cook the grains through or else
you prevent the next stage from working
properly so they should just get lightly
lightly toasted and the level that you
will make that malt
will um
will of course determine the color of
the beer
and so let's let's uh just try to malt
this right now
i'm going to put this on a very low heat
and all i really want to do is toast
these
i think maybe i can fit this whole thing
in there
we just want to stir this around
until it gets nice and toasty and then
we're gonna grind it up okay i think
that's just as much as that's gonna
handle so
to make sure i'm not burning them
you know what i think i'm going to get a
second pan going
and if you can smell this it's already
getting this lovely toasty aroma how
interesting
the person who does this would be called
a maltster and they would their job
would be to rake you know
a ton of malt a ton of grain at a time
and the advantage of this is that once
it's actually parched like this you can
make um beer any time of year so it's
very different from wine wine you'd need
to make when the harvest is ready
everyone has to you know you have to
press all the wine and put it in bottles
or casks to start with
this is very different you can actually
keep the malted barley around which is i
think why
you know most um
home brewers buy malted barley or they
buy what's called the wart which we'll
um we'll get to in just a few minutes
but let's watch this process carefully
some of them are actually already
getting a little toasty
maybe there
okay i'm gonna take these off now
[Music]
i'm going to set up this hand mill right
here
this basically replicates a hand kern
which would have been used from
prehistoric times really to grind wheat
even before wheat was cultivated
people would use a rotary current or a
hand current like this without the
plastic handle obviously you have a
another bigger stone that sits on top of
a sort of dome and then you turn it you
know with a stick or with a little uh
knob
but this is pretty much the exact same
technology
it just has to be bolted down very well
okay so here is our malted barley and
i'm just gonna feed it into the hopper
of this
millstone and as you can see what's
coming out here is very coarsely ground
barley malt
i'm just going to poke it through the
hopper to
help it along
they probably i mean you could do this
on a big mortar and pestle as well if
you didn't have a
grindstone like this
and i imagine
you know once you have animal power you
can make a much bigger millstone you can
hook up oxen to it or
a horse if you have it and then the
whole process goes much much quicker but
this is i'm gonna just tighten that a
little bit
obviously with a hand mill
this is gonna take a long time
[Music]
so as you can see this takes a really
long time i wonder how many calories you
expend in doing this just to get the
beer in the end but but you know
consider the beer as a food uh you know
this is something that men women and
children would have eaten and um gotten
their calories from and been nourished
by so what we're going to do at this
point
with this remaining
grain
is we're going to put it into the um
into this water this water i boiled i
actually didn't boil it i brought it up
to about 140 degrees and that means so
hot that you can't really put your
finger in for more than a couple of
seconds you can see i can keep it in
there for just
about
a second or so but what's going to
happen is i'm going to put this in here
and let this sit
for just an hour
let me mark the time
but this basically sits for an hour and
then this is strained through a cloth
and then you pour more water at 140
degrees over the grain this is called
sparging which will extract more sugars
from the grains themselves now at this
stage what you have is called wart
w-o-r-t bring this up to the boil
with a little bit of the mugwort which
we have here and whatever other herbs
you'd like to use let them boil together
for an hour
and then strain that to remove all the
green stuff
and the final liquid you'll cool to room
temperature and pour in a vessel big
enough to hold it we'll use this
stainless steel here a wooden barrel
would be ideal actually and today you
would add at this point some commercial
yeast for the specific kind of beer that
you want in the past they used yeast
from a former batch
or they used ambient yeast to just
colonize the liquid like you would do in
a sourdough starter and actually if you
have a sourdough starter you can use one
i have one in the corner there i'm
probably going to use that
and then
you know the next stage will depend
entirely on the temperature in the room
how active the microbes are in your
house but eventually you'll notice these
little bubbles rising and iberia roma
and then at that point you could
actually bottle it but it was not done
in the past not until like 15 16th
century until they had reliable bottles
it would usually go in a barrel
and they drank it room temperature
and flat so
so it's a it's a surprising taste for
americans i mean we like cold fizzy beer
um but um you know it's actually still
very good it's very appealing if you
think of it more as food than as a drink
refreshing drink you'll also notice that
the beer will come out very cloudy
because we're not going to filter it as
they didn't in the middle ages so the
yeast and other particles will still be
in there basically so think of it as a
kind of nutritious probiotic ferment of
grain and this was the typical drink
for breakfast actually before you go out
into the field to work men women and
children all drank beer it was much
safer than drinking the water usually
and there's um you know some argument
among historians whether this was a
really low alcohol small beer as it was
called you know you might have
four or five percent of alcohol in this
beer depending on how concentrated the
wart is um and that's nowhere near like
the strong hoppy ipas you can buy
nowadays that go up to 10
but it's still enough to make you a
little tipsy and i think we ought to
remember also the social context
remember no one is driving to work or
answering the phone so a little buzz
while you're planting seeds or
harvesting that's you know entirely
socially acceptable even if it's not
such a good idea to you know be swinging
a sickle while you're while you're a
little drunk but but there are of course
ritual occasions in the past when you
could drink um much more than that the
the church um you know also had uh uh
church ales or carnivals or feasts of
saints days they all involved drinking
and if you were a nobleman you might
drink beer during the day and then
switch to a much more expensive imported
wine later with dinner so the
distinctions in the patterns of
consumption only increase the more trade
expands in the later middle ages the
more luxury goods are brought in then
you might have you know a malwazia from
greece or something from the canary
islands but um for most people the
average everyday drink
from the middle ages
especially in northern europe would just
have been beer so give it a shot on your
own and see how it turns out as nicely
as ours will
you